okay team let's uh
get started for the day uh it's a
pleasure to see all of you guys
uh in case you don't remember i'm justin
i'm the third instructor of double six
that you probably forgot about
uh but you're gonna see a lot more of me
in the graph theory part of our course
because that's the
part of algorithms that i like if i were
reincarnated as a
theoretical computer scientist i would
probably go into this area hey guys
okay uh you know we have our phd admit
visit days coming up for the next
couple days i'm working on my like camp
counselor cheerleader
voice so you know don't make me
wake all of you guys up for the day
you're not gonna like it uh but in any
event uh
right so in in 606 if you look back at
the course
outline we're officially starting part
two of this class
uh there are a few corollaries to that
fact
so unless there are any questions about
that we'll get started with our our new
unit in 6006
which is a graph theory if you're
wondering there's a graph
on the the screen here but of course
we'll fill in a little bit more
information today
throughout our lecture when i was
learning how to teach which i'm still
doing one of
actually my phd advisor told me like if
you want somebody to learn something you
have to write it as big as possible and
so i'm
i'm really leaning into that that
approach today uh in our slides
so in any event uh right so today we're
gonna have our first lecture on on
graphs which i think
will somewhat be a review for many of
you guys and if it's not that's cool too
uh because we'll start from the
beginning and kind of build up all the
notions that we need
to understand and process graphs and
hopefully by the end of lecture
have some style of algorithm for
computing the shortest path from one
vertex to all the other ones
so in case we forgot a little bit of
terminology a graph
some people call this a network but
sometimes that term is overloaded with a
few different kind of variations on the
theme
is a collection of two things right
that's what this this parentheses
notation means
there's a set of vertices and a set of
edges
right and the edges uh like you can see
in the sort of third point on our screen
here
are a subset of v cross v now this is
fancy notation for something really
really simple
right because what is this telling me
this is telling me that an edge like in
the picture that we see on the screen
here
it's just something that connects two
vertices together
right so if i think of there being a
pair of vertices like the from and the
two
right then that is a subset of the cross
product of v in itself
right so hopefully the notation in that
third line on the screen makes some
sense this is just fancy notation
for edges or pairs of vertices but of
course inside of that notation there are
two
special cases that we care about uh in
this this class
uh one is is when you have a directed
graph and one is when you have an
undirected graph
because i said them in opposite order
from what's on the screen
right so in an undirected graph i guess
we still think of an edge like a pair of
vertices but really i should have
notated this slightly differently in
fact maybe i'll revise it in the slides
before
they go into ocw where instead of
writing
e equals uh w comma v i should write
in fact equals v comma w
and notice that there's a slight
difference between the notation on the
slide
and what i've written on the board which
is this set notation here
what's the difference between
parentheses and squiggly lines is that
this guy is unordered
this is a set of things and what's on
the board is
ordered right or what's on the screen
rather
and of course in an undirected edge
there's no such thing as an edge
from w to v being distinct from an edge
from v to w those are the same thing
right they're undirected it's just
it's a notion of connectivity whereas in
a directed graph now we're going to use
that parenthetical notation
to say that the edge from w to v
is different than the edge from v to w
that's going to make a big difference so
for example uh in the graph on the right
let's maybe redraw it uh on the board
here
so we have four vertices i drew this
last night and i'm hoping that this
example actually works
uh
like that can i get from the
upper right vertex to the lower left
vertex
following edges in this graph
i heard one person everybody on three
one
two three no right because if i wanted
to i mean maybe i think of drawing this
path here
but of course if i go from the upper
right
to the lower left this is like the
ugliest thing i've ever drawn i'm so
sorry
uh you notice that the edges are
pointing in the up direction here
and so i'd have to go kind of against
the stream of the water but that's not
allowable in the directed
graph case of course i'm already
anticipating the notion of a path which
we haven't really defined yet but i
think intuitively that's sort of the
the big difference between a directed
and undirected graph
that distinction makes sense to all of
y'all or if i manage to lose you in in
four minutes or less excellent
so i flip things a tiny tiny bit from
the course notes because i figured we'd
define what a graph
is first before telling you what the
applications are uh but in
in any event i think it's really not a
big stretch of the imagination to say
that grass are
like literally everywhere in our
everyday life right
any time that we come up with a network
of stuff connected together
implicitly the right abstraction often
in the back of our heads
is to think about a graph right so some
simple examples that i think would all
come to mind for us would be like
computer networks
right so the nodes or the vertices of
your graph uh in that case maybe our
computers and then
the edges are roughly the cables
connecting them together
in my very course understanding of how
networks work uh
or or maybe in a social network you know
the nodes are uh people in your social
network and the edges are like friend
relationships or like
you know frenemy relationships or
whatever in fact i think you could think
of both directed and
undirected uh versions of that
particular network
uh you know in road networks maybe you
know i'm working for google and i want
to
tell you the shortest path between your
house and mit of course
in order to do that and essentially
behind the scenes we're solving some
version
of computing the shortest path between
two vertices in a graph
that's a tiny bit of a lie in the sense
that there's a lot of structure in that
problem that we're not going to leverage
in this course right a road network is a
very special type of graph
and if you take an advanced course maybe
you'll say like well if i know a little
more about my graph i can do better than
the general case we'll talk about here
but the basic algorithms that we'll talk
about in 6006
are certainly relevant in that case and
are really the building blocks for what
goes on
in in the tools that are used every day
on your phone when you open google maps
or waze or whatever
and of course there's there's many
others right so for instance an example
uh that maybe is a little bit more
subtle would be the set of states and
transitions of a discrete thing so think
about
like a rubik's cube right so i could
make a graph where the node is every
configuration of my rubik's cube right
like every rotation
and then the edges are like can i get
from this configuration to that one by
making one
simple transition like one flip i don't
actually know the terminology in rubik's
cube i have a feeling you do
for one rotation twist thank you
and of course there are many other
places so for instance uh
you know my in my my day job here at mit
i typically teach computer graphics
courses and
actually graph theory although we talk
about it very differently appears in
that world
constantly because of course what's
sitting behind any 3d model on your
computer is a giant network
of triangles this is called a
triangulated surface like this taurus we
see here
and this is nothing more than a graph
and in fact if you squint at the
algorithms that we cover in 6838
you'll see that they're roughly just
graph algorithms in disguise
in fact if you take my graduate course
one thing we'll do we'll spend a lot of
time doing differential geometry and
then we'll step back 10 feet
and notice that exactly the algorithms
we're using for like computing
you know curvature and bendiness on
triangle meshes
just looks like a graph algorithm and
can be applied to networks in exactly
the same way so it'll be a nice kind of
fun reveal there and of course there's
one uh last kind of fun application
um i actually was gone the last couple
days at a conference on political
redistricting
and the funny thing is most of the
discussion at that conference
was about graph theory uh and and the
reason for that uh
is uh sort of a theme that shows up a
lot in geometry world
which is if i take my state in this case
i think these are the voting precincts
in some
state or another uh and i look at
adjacency relationships
then maybe i put a node for every
precinct and an edge anytime
they share a boundary with one another
well now i have a network
and and maybe a region on my graph is
like a connected piece of
of this this network uh and so anyway
this is one of these examples
where graphs and networks and
connectivity and so on just show up
literally no matter where you go they're
totally unavoidable uh
and so that's what we'll be spending
quite a bit of time on uh in this class
here
now you could easily take i would argue
at least
three entire courses on graph theory uh
here at mit
uh and you could easily build a phd uh
dissertation doing nothing more than
really simple problems on graphs
uh of course in this class we're we're
limited to you know some
some just a few lectures out of many uh
so we're going to make a couple
assumptions both on the problems we want
to solve
as well as on the graphs that we care
about uh so in particular uh one
simplifying assumption which actually
really doesn't affect
many of the algorithms we'll talk about
here but is worth noting explicitly
is that we'll mostly be thinking about a
particular type of graph which is a
simple graph
and in fact often depending on how you
define your graph you kind of
accidentally made your graph simple even
if you didn't intend to so for example
uh we wrote that our edges were a subset
of v cross v
uh which maybe means that i can't have
uh multiple edges that
uh you know sort of traverse the same
pair of vertices
so let's see an example of a graph that
is not simple
so sorry i haven't actually defined it a
simple graph is a graph that has no
self loops so i can't go from a vertex
to itself
and every edge is distinct so let's uh
make the most
non-simple graph we can think of like
let's say i have two vertices uh so
maybe
uh if i want to make my so there's a
graph right two vertices and one edge
this is simple if i wanted to be
annoying and make it not simple maybe
i'd take
this edge and i'd like duplicate it
three times just for
for fun that violates the second
assumption
and now to make it even worse i could
violate the first one by adding an edge
that goes from this vertex to itself
this is not
simple
i don't know what you would call it
actually a general graph i guess
complicated because it's not simple i
don't i don't know uh
yeah a multi-graph i always thought of
that as something anyways
it doesn't matter uh but in any event in
this class we're not going to worry
about this particular
circumstance and of course in many
applications of graph theory that's
totally reasonable
assumption to make any questions about
definition of a simple graph
okay so from now on whenever we think
about a graph in the back of our head
we're going to think of our graph as
simple
there's one nice property that a simple
graph has which i've written
in really big text on the screen here
which is that the edges
are big o of of of v squared and in fact
let's uh let's expand that formula just
a tiny bit
so there's sort of two cases uh right
one is when my graph is undirected
the other is my graph is is directed
yeah
so if i have a directed graph
well let's think about how many edges we
could possibly have right
so an edge is a pair of a from vertex
and a two vertex right
and i can never repeat it twice right
that's that's sort of like the uh
the second assumption here right so in
particular
what do we know we know that mod e or
rather the number of edges in our graph
is upper bounded by what well
i can take any pair of vertices
like that but i have to be a little bit
careful because my graph is directed
right so from and to matter here so this
is
v choose 2 is saying that i can take any
unique pair of vertices
but i have to put a factor of 2 in front
of it to account for the fact that the
source and the target can be flipped
back and forth
and of course if i want to do the
undirected i don't have to worry about
that
right we'll get e here is less than or
equal to just
mod v choose two right so this is just a
fancy uh
way of saying that every edge consists
of two vertices and my edges are unique
and one thing if you just write down the
formula for uh our binomial coefficient
here
is we'll see that both of these things
oops oh yeah
all right worst mod v square here
and that makes perfect sense right
because of course an edge is a pair of
vertices you kind of expect there to be
a square there
yes
i'm so sorry i can't hear you sorry so
the two comes from the background that's
from this one
yes exactly so the the two uh for the
directed case
comes from the fact that an edge from
v2w
is different than an edge from w to v
right so remember that the binomial uh
coefficient here
is just counting the number of ways that
i can choose two things from a set of
size v
but it doesn't care about ordering yeah
any other questions
fabulous so why is this going to matter
well these sorts of bounds i mean they
might seem a little bit obvious to you
but we're going to write down graph
algorithms and now when we analyze the
runtime and the space that they take
we now have like sort of two different
numbers that we can think about right
the number of vertices
and the number of edges right and so for
instance if i write down an algorithm
whose runtime is proportional to the
number of edges
maybe then generically i could also
think of the algorithm as having a
runtime that looks like the number of
vertices squared
unless i put some additional assumptions
on my my graph right and so there's some
connection between all of these
different constants
and it's useful to kind of keep that the
back of our head that sometimes you'll
see a bunch of different expressions
that really are encoding
roughly the same relationship just in
different language
of course that also means that we can be
more precise right so sometimes a graph
is what we would call sparse
so in my universe almost all graphs that
i deal with in my day-to-day life are
extremely sparse
this is a consequence of topology uh and
and because of that
an algorithm that scales like the number
of edges might actually be much
preferable to an algorithm that scales
like the number of vertices squared
because
in practice often there are fewer edges
than like every single possible pair
right uh and and so that's the sort of
reason why it's worth thinking about
these numbers
okay so let's continue making boring uh
definitions here uh
so some other ones that we should think
about uh involve the
topology or the connectivity of our
graph in particular thinking about
neighbors
right so in general we kind of think
about pairs of vertices as being
neighbors of one another uh if there's
an
edge between them we have to be a little
bit careful uh because of course
uh when we have a directed edge we have
to be careful who's on the
sort of giving and the receiving end of
this this neighbor relationship
yeah so let's draw a really really
simple graph
so here's vertex zero here's vertex one
here's vertex two
and maybe we'll have an edge going up
edge going down and then a cycle
here okay now we can define
a lot of different notions of neighbors
like the outgoing neighbor set the
incoming neighbor set
uh and and the basic idea here is that
we want to keep track of edges going
from a vertex and
edges pointing into one yeah so for
instance the outgoing neighbor set which
we're going to
notate as adj plus here
what is the outgoing neighbor set of
node 0 here well if we take a look
notice that there's one
edge going out of node 0 and it points
to node 2.
so of course this is set which just
contains one other node
and similarly the incoming neighbor set
of node zero well notice that there's
one incoming neighbor from vertex one
so that is a set like that
now of course in an undirected graph uh
the sort of distinction between these
two
things doesn't matter so if you look at
our final bullet point here
uh often in the undirected case we just
drop that plus or minus superscript
because it sort of doesn't matter
yeah uh in any event there's one
additional piece of terminology that
matters quite a bit
which is degree and this is nothing more
than just
counting the size of this set right so
the out degree is the number of edges
that point out of a vertex
and the in degree is the number of edges
that point in
so notice in in this case both of those
numbers are are one
uh let's see an example where they're
not so in node one
notice there's two edges that come out
so the out degree
of of node one is two there's one edge
that points in
so the in degree is one
okay so often why why are we going to do
this well we're going to write a lot of
graph algorithms that like
have a for loop over the neighbors of a
given vertex and then this this degree
number is going to come into play
um is worth uh bounding these things
just a tiny bit so uh
in particular one thing we could think
about
ah i write too big and i'm gonna run out
of space really quickly here
um is the following so let's take a look
at
all of the possible nodes inside of my
graph
and now let's sum up all of their
degrees right so like i'm going to
let's see if i look at this graph you
know then notice there's you know
there's three
out three edges adjacent to this vertex
here three edges adjacent to that one
two adjacent to this so
i sum them all together so just a
convenient bound to have around
uh is to sum these things because we're
gonna have algorithms that look like for
every vertex
for every neighbor do something so we
might as well know kind of
roughly uh how much time that's gonna
take um
let's think about this so what do we
know in an
undirected graph every edge is adjacent
to two vertices
right so if we think about how we
account for degree
what do we know well we know that an
edge sort of contributes to the degree
of two different vertices
right so
if we think about it uh carefully here
what we're going to see is that
if our graph is undirected
oh oops sorry
is that right wait i'm backward again so
if i have
a graph with two vertices and one edge
and it is undirected
notice that
the number of edges here is one what is
the the sum of the degree
well it's one plus one equals two yeah
so there's a 2 here if my my
graph is undirected
and e if my graph is directed
if what i'm counting is just the
outgoing
degree that makes sense i think i
managed to totally botch that sentence
so maybe let's let's try that again
so if i'm counting just the number of
edges pointing out of every vertex
and i count that over all of the
possible vertices
then there's two cases right one is
directed and one is undirected
right so in the undirected case you get
a two here because essentially every
edge is simultaneously ingoing and
outgoing
whereas you get a one as a coefficient
in the directed case
that makes sense i'm sorry i botched
that for a second
okay excellent okay so that's going to
be a useful bound for us
later on now we think about graphs of
course we just spent the last couple
weeks thinking about data structures
we should think about how to store a
graph on a computer and there's many
different options
in fact really one thing you can do is
sort of pair
just like when we talked about sets
right there were many different ways to
store sets and one way to think about it
was
depending on how we're going to interact
with that set we might choose one data
structure or another
to sort of optimize the types of of
interactions we're going to have with
that set and make them as fast as
possible
it's exactly the same story uh for a
graph
right so for instance the world's
dumbest
representation of a graph would be to
just have a long list of edges right so
for example
uh for this graph up here maybe i have
you know
0 1 that's an edge and then
zero two that's another edge and then
one
two and then two one
there's a big list of edges really sad i
don't care about the order
one oh you're right i'm sorry yeah the
edge points up
thanks eric or not eric jason
okay so let's say that i have a graph
algorithm and
i'm going to have to do something like
check whether there exists an edge from
v to w a bunch of times
how long is that going to take in in
this data structure well if i just have
like a hot mess disorganized list of
edges
and want to know does there exist an
edge from v to w all i can do is write a
for loop that just goes along this set
and says like is this edge that i'm
looking for
no is that the edge i'm looking for no
right so every single time i want to
find an edge
it's going to take me time proportional
to the number of edges in my graph which
could potentially
be up to v squared yeah so this is not
such a great representation
of a graph on my computer right so if
we're thinking back at our data
structure we might say okay so an edge
list is probably not the way to go
although notice that the way we notated
like what is a graph kind of looks like
an edge list uh but in any event uh the
the more common thing to do
is to sort something like an adjacency
list so
uh right so the basic idea of an
adjacency list
is that what i'm going to store uh is a
set
that maps a vertex
u to everything adjacent to you
right so in other words i'm just going
to keep track of all the outgoing edges
from every vertex
and now i have to decide how am i going
to store this object
and oftentimes we're going to have to
answer queries like does there exist an
edge from v to w
right so how could i do that first i
would look up v
and i get back sort of a list or set of
of all the things that are adjacent to v
and i have to query that thing and i
want it to be pretty fast
so maybe what i do is i store
the set of adjacent stuff
as something like a direct access array
or a hash table
um to make that look up uh fast
so for example uh how long would it take
i see i'm going to finish the sentence
here
uh how long would it take me to check if
an edge exists in my my graph
well what would i do i would first pull
out this object and then i'd look inside
of here
right so if i stored this as a hash
table then an expected time i would have
order one lookup right because this is
order one
and then you have another order one look
up there so we went from v
squared to one with one simple trick
yes
that's a great question um so there's a
design decision here i'm sorry in my
head
i think a lot about undirected graphs
and i'm going to make this mistake a lot
and i'm glad that you caught me
um there's a totally reasonable thing to
do which is maybe just to keep track of
the outer edge
of the outgoing edges for every vertex
this is a design decision for an
algorithm
maybe i want to keep track of the
incoming edges whatever i just have to
make sure that
it aligns with what i want to do with my
graph later yep excellent point
sorry as a geometry person we rarely
encounter
directed graphs but it's important to
keep remembering that not everybody
works on the same problems that i do
okay um now if i wanted to be totally
extreme about it uh
as just a third example of
representation which actually in some
sense you could think of like an
adjacency list we need an adjacency
matrix where now i just
keep like a giant v by v array of like
does this edge
exist does that edge exist now it's
really really easy
to check if an edge exists
but now let's say that i make a graph
algorithm that's going to have a for
loop over all the neighbors of some
vertex
right so here that if i wanted to loop
over all the neighbors of u
i could do that in time proportional to
the number of neighbors of u
but if i just have a big adjacency
matrix just a bunch of binary values
like
for every pair of vertices are these
vertices adjacent yay or nay
if i want to iterate over all my
neighbors now i have to iterate over
all the vertices and check is that
number one and then do something
so actually that can incur some
additional time and additional space
does that make sense so in any event
that's a
sort of a lazy man's graph
representation i use it a lot when i'm
coding
because adjacency matrices are easy to
work with but it does incur a lot of
additional space
and it's not always the most efficient
thing even if you have the space because
iterating over neighbors
it actually can take quite a bit of time
okay so
the real point of our lecture today is
to start introducing sort of the
canonical problem that we all worry
about on graphs
which is computing paths in particular
shortest paths
uh so the first thing we should do is of
course define what a
a path is on a graph so we're going to
think about our graph like a road
network
right let's think of maybe every node
here as an intersection right so this is
a
roughly kendall square see it's a it's a
square um
but in in any event uh let's say that i
want to find
uh maybe question one would be you know
does there exist a way to get from
vertex 1 to vertex 3
and then a better question to ask would
be does there exist a short way to get
from vertex 1 to vertex 3
then of course the first thing i have to
do is define my enemy to define what i'm
looking for
which is a path so a path is nothing
more than a sequence of vertices in a
graph
where every pair of adjacent vertices in
that sequence is an edge
i think this all aligns with our
intuition of what a path is in a graph
so for instance here's a path p equals
v1 v2 v3
so notice that there's an edge from v1
to v2 and also an edge from v2 to v3 so
it satisfies
the assumptions set forth in our
definition
what would not be a path in our graph
would be like v1 comma v3 right because
there's no edge there
okay so if we talk about paths then
there's a very natural
notion which is the length length i
guess you can think of like the number
of vertices in your path minus one
or uh the number of edges that your your
path traverses those are the same thing
right so for instance the length of the
path p here is two
everybody see that a very common coding
bug that i encounter a lot is
adding one to that number by accident um
because of course there's one more
vertex in your path than there are edges
okay and and there are many different uh
there could be potentially
more than one uh path between any pair
of vertices so
let's say that i have an undirected
graph that looks like the following
so it's just a square plus a diagonal so
here are
nodes right so then a perfectly valid
path
from the lower left to the upper right
would be to go one over and one
up but of course there's a more
efficient way to get from the lower left
to the upper right which is to go across
the diagonal
and so when we talk about the shortest
path it's nothing more than the length
of the path that has the fewest number
of edges or vertices
in it between any pair of vertices in my
graph
okay so this is our enemy this is what
we're after is computing the shortest
path between vertices in a graph uh and
this is the thing uh that we'll be
talking about quite a bit in this course
because of course it's a very practical
matter right like when i want to solve
routing problems i want to like move
packets on my network
i prefer not to well unless i'm doing
tour i'd prefer them you know not to hit
too many uh computers in between
uh then maybe i want a computer shortest
path or or uh
you know on a surface maybe i want to uh
you know move information in a way
that's not too far away
but of course there's sort of many
variations on that theme when we talk
about uh shortest paths or even just
existence of a path right so these are
three sort of model problems that we
might solve on a graph
right so the first one uh which in in
this course we're calling a single pair
reachability
with the idea that i take two vertices s
and t
on my graph g and i ask you does there
exist
a path between s and t so what would be
the sort of extreme example
where uh uh this graph this problem
may not always give back the answer yes
right like in somehow in our head i
think
we think of all graphs as being
connected right but
a perfectly valid graph the way we've
defined it would be like 10 vertices and
no edges
right this this function would be very
easy to code if that were the only graph
you ever cared about
uh but but in any event the existence of
a path
is already a query that takes a little
bit of algorithmic thinking we haven't
we haven't figured out how to do that
yet
right now another problem we can solve
will be the shortest path right given a
graph
and two vertices we might say well how
far apart are these vertices in my graph
uh if i want to use the shortest
possible distance from one to the other
notice that i can use the second problem
to solve the first one
right because what's the shortest with
the length of the shortest path between
two vertices that don't have a path
between them
infinity or shrug that's actually a
totally valid answer
yeah um that's right so how could i
implement the reachability code
well i could call my shortest path code
and it gives me infinity
then i return no it's not reachable and
if it gives me not infinity i return yes
right so remember that a key idea in
algorithms class is this idea of
reduction that i can like use one
function to solve another
right so in this case if we can solve
shortest path then we can certainly
solve
the reachability problem by calling that
piece of code
and then finally we could talk about
single source shortest path
so notice now that there's only one
input node here s
so what this problem is saying is give
me the length of the shortest path from
s to every single other vertex in my
graph
that makes sense so like maybe i return
a big array with all the information
every single shortest distance
so can we solve single pair shortest
path using single source shortest path
absolutely right i could you know take s
in my single pair shortest path problem
compute the shortest path from s to
literally everything else
and then throw away all that information
except the shortest path to t and
and now i'm good now i haven't justified
the this is the fastest possible way to
solve that second problem but at least
it shows that if i can solve problem
three
i can also solve problems to if i can
solve problem two i can also solve
problem one
so uh in today's lecture we're just
gonna worry about
uh problem three in other words these
things are sort of listed in increasing
order of their their difficulty
okay so in order to think about the
single short source shortest path
problem we're going to make one
additional construction
uh and this is an idea uh called the
shortest oops the shortest path tree
i got lazy drawing powerpoint slides at
2am yesterday and and instead
thought i'd i'd draw a picture on the
board so
uh let's uh draw a graph
so here we have a a b
i'm going to use letters instead of
numbers to refer to nodes
from now on because i don't want to
confuse the length of the shortest path
of the index of my uh
my node uh so here's a b c
i'm going to match my notes here d
e f
here's a graph again undirected because
your instructor likes to think about
undirected graphs but i know i'm going
to get feedback that i shouldn't have
done that later
but in any event let's say that i want
to compute the shortest path from a to
everything else or the length rather
so first of all even without talking
about an algorithm i think it's pretty
easy to guess what it is right so
clearly the shortest path from a a has
length available like that
does everybody agree with me that the
numbers i've decorated here are the
length of the shortest path
from a to everything else
but what have i not done i haven't told
you
how to actually compute the path i'm
just giving you the length of the path
right so i might want a piece of code
that in addition to doing single source
shortest path
length also gives me single shortest
single source shortest path so initially
when i think about that i might think
about well how do i even write down a
data structure
that can store all of those paths right
well every
path could have like v vertices in it
right like it could be the
for whatever reason there's like a lot
of branching in my graph and all the
paths are super long
actually i guess i have to think about
whether branching would make them longer
or shorter
uh but but in any event i could have a
really boring data structure that just
for every single vertex keeps track
of the shortest path from a to that
vertex
how big would that data structure be
well the only bound i have on the length
of a path is that
well you know certainly at most it takes
all the vertices in my graph
right then any one path will take v
space so that would take v squared space
total that wouldn't be so good right
because
somehow i have an amount of information
on my graph currently that's linear
right it's just the length of the path
if i want to actually reconstruct that
path initially it sort of spiritually
feels like i need way more space to do
that
um but the answer is that we actually
don't that we're going to only need
linear space and the idea for that
is to store an object called the
shortest path tree yes
so the question was about recursion we
haven't actually written down any graph
algorithms so we're going to defer on
that and until
until we actually recurse uh and then
we'll think about it more carefully
yeah but it's a totally reasonable
question there are plenty of recursive
graph algorithms out there uh
and and then we'll have to uh do our
accounting very carefully for sure
right so uh instead uh we're going to
define an object called the shortest
path tree
and the basic trick here is to say well
how did i get from a to c
well there's always a vertex which is
its predecessor
on the shortest path and shortest paths
have this really beautiful property
right which is that the shortest path
from a to c if i truncate it
right so like it goes a to b to c
then the truncated one is also the
shortest path to that previous vertex
right so let's think about that a little
bit because that sentence was as usual
poorly phrased by your
instructor so let's say that i have the
shortest path from a to d
which is is very clearly a b
c d i think we can all agree
and now i take like this sub list i just
look from a to c
is there ever a circumstance when this
is not the shortest path or a shortest
path from a to c
no right because if it were right if
there existed a shorter path from a to c
i could like splice it in here and find
a shortest path from a to d
you see that so based on that reasoning
rather than storing like this giant set
of shortest paths
sort of actually applying in some sense
this recursive uh a
suggestion uh instead i can just think
of the one
vertex that's before me in my shortest
path i'm going to trace backwards so
let's take a look at our graph here
essentially the object i'm going to keep
track of is like a predecessor
right so what is the predecessor of f on
the shortest path it's actually either d
or e it doesn't matter in this case so
maybe the predecessor is e
for fun right
what's the predecessor of e well clearly
the previous edge
or vertex on the shortest path is c
similarly for d now we have b
and a we have a bunch of arrows that
point this way
right so for every vertex i'm just going
to start an arrow pointing toward the
previous vertex on the shortest path i'm
not going to store the whole shortest
path
just the very last edge
so first of all how much storage does
this take
it takes v space do you see that or the
size of the vertices space
because every vertex just has to store
one thing which is the previous vertex
on its shortest
path yeah now what is my algorithm for
tracing shortest paths it's really
simple right i just start walking along
these edges
all the way until i get back to a
now this object is called a shortest
path tree notice i snuck in
one additional word which is tree why is
that can i ever have a cycle in this
graph
it wouldn't really make any sense right
these are shortest paths you should be
able to kind of follow the gradient back
to the
original vertex okay
so in other words i'm going to basically
decorate my graph
with one additional thing we'll call it
p of v which is the previous vertex
on the shortest path from my source
point to my vertex v
and what i think i've tried to argue to
you guys today is that if i have this
information that's actually enough to
reconstruct the shortest path
i just keep you know taking p v and then
p of p of v and then p of p
p v and so on which sounds more
complicated than it is uh until i
trace back to my original vertex and
this object
conceptually is called the shortest path
tree any questions about that
yes
ah okay so the question was let's say
that uh our colleague here
added an edge this is a
great question you know somebody was
evil
my adversarial neural network stick an
edge here
because it was adversarial and it wanted
my shortest path code to fail
and now somehow the the tree that i gave
you is is no longer correct
and my answer to that is yes why is that
well by
adding this edge here my the length of
my shortest path changed right
the shortest path from a to d is now one
so this tree is no longer valid i need a
new tree
so now what would be the uh the previous
like p
of of d here well rather than being c
it would be a yeah so that's absolutely
right
and it actually is reflective of a
really annoying property of shortest
paths
which is if i add one edge to my graph
the length of the shortest path to every
vertex can change
well i guess with the exception of the
source vertex
yeah and uh that's actually a really
big headache in certain applications so
uh for instance and then i'll shut up
about applications and do math again
um i work a lot with 3d models and
there's a big data set of 3d models of
like ballerinas
and ballerinas are really annoying
because sometimes they put their hands
together like that
and then suddenly the shortest path
between your fingers
goes from like your entire body to like
zero
and so incremental algorithms for
computing shortest path can
can fail here right because i have to
update like everything if i accidentally
glued together
fingers like that um so anyway i'll let
you think about how you might fix that
problem and
if you want to know more you should take
6838 yes
if you change your source node the
shortest path will change again yeah so
this is going to be one of these really
boring things i'm going to keep
answering like
anytime i change anything about my
problem i change my source i change my
edges i have to just recompute all the
shortest paths
there are obviously algorithms out there
that don't do that uh
but we're not going to think about them
yet okay
so as usual i've talked too much and
left myself about 10 minutes to
do the actual algorithm that's
interesting uh in in the lecture here
although actually it's really not so
complicated so i think we'll do okay
which is how do i actually compute
shortest paths yeah and the basic thing
we're going to do
is is sort of build on this this tree
analogy here
we're going to define one more object
which i really like actually i enjoy
this from from jason's notes because it
looks like calculus
and i i enjoy that um and that's an idea
of a level set and so this is a whole
set of things
l sub k and these are all the vertices
that are distance k
away from my source right so for
instance if my source vertex
in in this example is the vertex all the
way on the left then l0
obviously contains just that vertex
right l1
is the the next one l2 is the third one
but now l3 is a set of
three vertices right because those are
all the things that are distance three
away from the source that's what i've
labeled in pink here
okay so that's all that this uh this
notation uh here means
oh oops i've made a slight typo because
in this class distance is delta and not
d but
whatever the shortest distance that's
absolutely right
so for instance i could have a very long
distance from l0 to l1 right i could
just
flip back and forth between l0 and l1
maybe go over to l4 and then go back
but that wouldn't be a terribly helpful
thing to compute
that's absolutely right yes
ah the red background is the set l so
for example
l three contains these three vertices
because they're
all the things that are distance three
away from the left i got a little too
slick drawing my uh my diagram
like late last night i'm kind of proud
of it
okay so essentially if i wanted to
compute the length of the shortest path
from vertex
all the way on the left to all the other
vertices um
one way to do that would be to compute
all these level sets and then just sort
of check what level set i'm in
right so we're going to introduce an
algorithm
called breath first search which does
roughly uh that
so uh breath first search the way we'll
introduce it today uh is going to be an
algorithm for computing all of those
level sets l sub i
uh and then from that we can construct
the length and even the the shape of the
the shortest path so now i'm going to
move to my handwritten notes
okay uh and here's what our algorithm is
going to do
i'm going to write it in a slightly
different way than what's in the course
notes on the screen but but only
slightly
so first of all one thing i think we can
all agree on
is that level set zero oh that's cool
this chaka
bifurcated uh it contains one node
what should that node be the source
right
because the only thing that's distance
away is zero away from the source is the
source node
okay uh and in addition to that
we can initialize the distance from the
source to itself
everybody on three what is the distance
from the source to itself one two three
zero thank you so you're waking up now
it's it's getting it's almost eleven
twelve what time is it almost twelve
okay
and then finally uh well maybe initially
we don't really know anything about the
array p so we just make it empty right
because p
of the source is somehow doesn't matter
right because once i made it back to the
source i'm done computing shortest paths
so we're gonna write an algorithm that
computes all the level sets
and fills in this array p and fills in
the distances
all in one big shot we're going to call
it breath first search
okay so let's do that
so we can use the notation uh here and
notice that there's basically an
induction going on
right which is i'm gonna compute level
set one from level set zero
level set two from level set one and so
on until i fill in all my level sets
does that make sense uh so here's a
slightly different way
to notate the same thing i'm going to
use a while loop which i know is like
slightly non-kosher
uh but that's okay um so i'm going to
initialize
a number i to be one this is going to be
like our counter
i'm going to say while
the previous uh level set is not empty
meaning that potentially there's a path
that goes through the previous level set
into the next one right because as soon
as one of my my levels is empty
notice that all the rem like the li for
even bigger eye are also going to be
empty
there's like never a case when there's
something distance uh not distance i
but then distance like i plus five okay
so now what am i gonna do well
let's think back to our graph
right so like now i know that this guy
is just in zero away that's what i
started with so now i'm going to look at
all the neighbors of this vertex
i'm going to make them distance 1 away
that make sense
and similarly here this guy's distance
2.
and eventually i'm going to get in
trouble because maybe
well what's a good example here i won't
even try to draw
uh i could run into trouble if i don't
want to add a vertex
twice to uh two different level sets
right once i've i've
put it in l i then i don't want to put
it in like l i plus 5 because i already
know that assistance
ioa does that make sense okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
iterate over all the vertices
in my previous level set
and now i'm going to look at every
vertex that is adjacent
to you right because what do i know i
know that if i can get to u
in i minus one steps how many steps
should it take me
to get to any neighbor of you
i steps right because i can go through
the path which is length i minus one
add one additional edge and now get to
that new guy
right so what can i do i can iterate
over all v
which is in the adjacent
uh set of of u but to be a little bit
careful
because like what if i have an edge
backwards so like for instance here
i have an edge back to the source i
guess this is
yeah that's a valid example like i
wouldn't want to add the source to like
the third level set
because i already added it in a previous
guy right
so i want to get rid of the union
of all of the previous level sets
of uh does that make sense so in other
words i'm
only going to look at the adjacent
vertices that i haven't visited yet in
my level set computation algorithm
and all i have to do is update my arrays
right so in particular
i'm going to add
vertex v uh to level set
i because i haven't seen v yet i'm going
to set the distance
from s to v um
equal to i right because i'm currently
filling in my level set i
and then finally what is p
of v what is the previous vertex to v in
my shortest path for my source
it's you right because that's the guy in
the previous level set that i'm building
my path from
right i'm gonna say that to you
and then sorry i ran out of space but i
also have to
increment i okay
so what does this algorithm do it's just
building one level set at a time we go
back to our picture
right so it starts by initializing l0 to
just be the source vertex
then it looks at all the edges coming
out of that in that case just one
makes that length one and so on right
and so this is just incrementally
building up all these level sets
now there's a pretty straightforward
proof by induction uh that this
algorithm correctly computes the ls the
ps and the deltas which is all the
information that we need
uh to compute the uh the shortest path i
think you guys can do that in your
recitation if you still need a little
bit of induction uh proof uh practice
here
um and the final thing that we should
check is what is the run time of this
algorithm
i'm gonna squeeze in there just at the
last second here
so let's take a look so first of all
i did something a little oh oops uh
no that's okay um in my algorithm
actually in step 0 i had to make an
array which was the size equal to the
number of vertices
and remember that in in 606 how much
time does it take to allocate memory
yeah it takes the amount of time
proportional to the amount of memory
that i allocate
right so already that stuff i see your
hand but we're low on time so we're
gonna make it to the end
um already we've incurred v time right
because our shortest path array takes v
space
but in addition to that we have this
kind of funny for loop
where for every node i have to visit all
of its neighbors
now first of all do i ever see a node
twice here
no right because i'm going in order of
distance
and the second thought i've seen a node
in one level set it can't be in another
right that's sort of our basic
construction here
well conveniently for you guys we've
already proved exactly the formula that
we need and if i'm lucky i didn't erase
it yeah
here we are if we take a look here this
is exactly the scenario that we're in
right because what did we do we iterated
over all the nodes in our graph
and then we iterated over all the
neighbors of those nodes and that's the
basic computational time in our
algorithm
so that for loop or that while loop
rather in my code is incurring
time proportional to the number of edges
so what is the total run time for for
breadth-first search
well we need to construct that array
even so just as step 0 we've incurred v
time
and then we have to iterate over
something that takes at most the number
of edges
so overall our algorithm takes big o
of mod v plus mod e
time now notice that this is you might
view this as kind of redundant by the
way in this i have a little bit of a
quibble with jason but in this class
we'll call this a linear time
algorithm because it's linear in the
space that you're using to store your
graph
i think that's a little fishy personally
because this scale could scale
quadratically in v but
i digress um in any event
uh right why do we need both of these
terms here
well notice that you know if i had no
edges in my graph
right now this term is going to dominate
but as i add i just to my graph
this thing could go up to v squared
right so this is somehow a more
informative expression than just saying
well at worst this is v
squared time does that make sense this
is a slightly better formula to have
okay so with that we just squeaked into
the finish line we have an algorithm for
computing shortest paths
uh and i'll see you guys again i guess
on tuesday